Vi är inga andra företag skulle jag säga som lägger den typen av engagemang och dedikering till fria vikter någon annanstans i världen.
Och det gör vi för att vi brinner för det, vi har vårt arv, vi har vår position.
Det där är egentligen en styrka hos oss.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Erik Blomberg från Eleiko, och även om alla i min värld vet vilka Eleiko är, så kanske inte, nu för tiden är ju inte detta riktigt en träningspodd, utan det är mer en entreprenörspodd, men ni har gjort en helt bizarr resa får man ändå säga.
Men vad gör Eleiko?
Ja, kul att vara med.
Eleiko, vi är ju inom styrketräningsbranschen, så vi utvecklar och tillverkar styrketräningsutrustning.
Ni tenderar ju att vara det enda varumärket som folk kanske har koll på som inte är i branschen.
Så när man säger, ja men Eleiko, kanske ni har hört, det är de som är på OS, då brukar ju folk ändå känna till er.
Är det liksom det som har blivit er ett signum på något sätt?
Ja det får man säga, det är ju egentligen historien.
Tillbaka, Eleiko har ju funnits som företag sedan 1927 egentligen, och gjorde egentligen helt andra saker först.
Elektriska produkter.
Eleiko står för elektriska installationer, kommanditbolag från början.
Men det var ju på 50-talet som en tyngdlyftare jobbade på företaget, och ville ta fram en tyngdlyftningsstång, som kunde hålla en hel tävling.
Och det gjordes också, och lanserades på ett VM i Stockholm.
Och det är ju egentligen skivstången, som har verkligen varit Eleikos kärnprodukt och hjälteprodukt genom åren.
Och den har verkligen synts på OS, VM och stora mästerskap genom åren.
Varför valde man att göra den stången där?
Det är ju inte en helt krockren koppling.
Nej, inte till den ursprungliga produkten.
Det var ju stålbearbetning som blev kompetensen i företaget ganska tidigt.
Så det var ju att tillverka olika typer av stålbearbetade produkter.
Och vi säger att det var ett Woffeljärn som blev den mest kända produkten.
Men det var även brödrostar, det var en del portavla element och ugnar.
Och sen var det en del legotillverkning till Volvo, till exempel, och ett andra företag.
Så det var ju stålbearbetning som byggdes upp som en kompetens i företaget.
Och det var ju då den som kunde reseras på en skivstång.
Att tillverka en skivstång av högsta kvalitet.
Hur lång tid tog det innan man lade ner den andra businessen och bara gick över och blev i Leiko, så som vi känner i Leiko?
Det tog ganska många år egentligen.
Så kan man säga att företaget utvecklades i två riktningar.
Så att det är Leiko.
Det fanns en annan del som växte faktiskt bättre än sportdelen i början.
Och det var inom miljöteknik.
Så om man går upp i Stockholm på Sturegatan eller några ställen så kan man titta ner i backen ibland och så ser man att det står Leiko på gatulocken.
Och under där finns det gamla återvinningscentraler där man kunde återvinna sitt hushållsavfall.
Och det var egentligen en bättre del av företaget i början.
Och då låg sportdelen där och levde lite sitt egna liv ganska länge och miljöteknikdelen utvecklades bättre och sen hamnade den inom en annan företagskonstellation framåt i 80-90-talet.
Hur nöjd är du att det inte blev den delen som du fick jobba med istället?
För visst är ni ett familjeföretag?
Du är någon sorts ätling.
Ja jag är i andra generationen så min pappa, det var inte hans sida som startade Eleiko från början, utan det var en annan familj här i Hanstad.
Men där någonsin kände han den familjen väl och han växte upp med sonen då till de som grundade det.
Så han var väldigt nära företaget från början, från Barnsben.
Efter lite turer, när inte den familjen kunde skifta riktigt så hamnade det i att min pappa köpte Eleikos sportdelen på 90-talet, sent 90-tal.
Så han var emotionellt koklad till företaget tidigt men sen var det först på, jag tror det var 1998 som han då köpte bolaget och började utveckla det inom vår familjs ägo.
När var det du kom in som vd?
Jag kom in 2012.
Sen dess har ni ju, alltså ni var ju ett coolt företag innan men ni har ju gjort en rätt bizarr resa sen dess.
Nu var jag inne och kollade, nu omsatte ni 660 miljoner här.
Ni har ju liksom levlat upp sen de dagarna hur kaxig känner du dig på familjeträffar för att det är du som har lett den här tillväxten?
Nej, där ska jag säga att det är man inte så kaxig och har aldrig varit riktigt, utan det är alltid väldigt, det är stort engagemang från alla och alla känner ju företaget ganska väl så att alla har sina åsikter.
Så det är det, det är nog inte, den kan man nog inte riktigt komma över någon gång.
Jag fattar, sitter de fortfarande och pratar om gamla minnen och hur de gjorde förr och sånt där?
Får du aldrig prata om hur du gör nu?
Min pappa, jag tror att jag är över 2012, min pappa hade drivit det då som vd ett antal år.
Hans mål var att nå upp till 100 miljoner i omsättning.
När han köpte företaget så omsatte det 10 miljoner.
Det var bara den här väldigt nischkärda marknaden mot internationella tävlingar, tyngdlyftning, styrkelyftning.
Det var hans stora mål att verkligen komma upp till den 100 miljoners nivå.
När han lämnade över till mig och pratade inför alla personalen så sa han att det är de första 100 miljonerna som är den svåra att köra på.
Men vi har ju haft en resa sedan dess.
Nu har vi alltid haft tillväxt i fokus.
Vi har haft ett mål att vi ska växa 20 procent per år, vilket vi i princip har gjort mestadels under åren.
Så det har varit väldigt mycket tillväxt i fokus.
Hur har sortimentsberäddningen sett ut där?
För om ni började med skivstänger så gissar jag att vikter var nästa grej.
Hur har det sett ut genom åren?
Ja det var ju mera förstås.
Det kan man säga, hela skivstången med vikter var ju det nästan det första som togs fram.
Sen har det varit ett väldigt specialiserat sortiment mot professionell lyftning.
Det man kan säga är att vår familj har gjort den här resan där vi successivt har expanderat sortimentet och vänt oss till nya målgrupper.
Tittar man på bara tyngdlyftning och styrkeluftsmarknad så är det en väldigt liten marknad.
Det är inte en tillväxt i sig på det planet.
Utan den stora tillväxten har ju verkligen legat inom dels andra idrotter som använder den här typen av utrustning men sedan kommersiella gym.
Så det är ju gymmarknaden som segment som har varit det mest intressanta för oss.
Och sen på senare år också, mer och mer mot hemma med kunder.
Det måste ju vara en problematik i att vara i ett så nischat mot, vad ska vi kalla, du kanske är bättre än någon, måste du veta att den där sista procenten kostar ju jävligt mycket.
Man kan ju ta fram en stång som klarar, låt oss bara ponera typ 700 kilo eller 900 kilo, och så ska den vara kalibrerad.
Det är jävligt lätt kanske att kalibrera den upp till 50 gram från, ja vad ska vi säga, från liksom matchvikt, men den där sista grammet eller sista procenten är ju den dyra procenten.
Hamnar ni aldrig liksom i de här diskussionerna i att, fan om vi ska röra oss mot en mer mainstream kund, då kanske inte den sista procenten behövs, då kanske vi bara behöver göra en halv procent av den kunde, hur ofta uppstår de eller hur hanterar ni de tankarna?
Det ni är med ganska ofta måste jag säga, för det är ju egentligen en stora utmaning med att ha en position som anses då världsledande inom sitt område.
Och när vi ska utveckla in i nya segment och nya produkter, så är det ju, vi har ju en, alltså vårt befintliga sortiment guider egentligen och ställer förväntningar på vilka nya produkter vi tar fram.
Så den där är en utmaning och det finns en risk att man överutvecklar eller att man går för hårt med detaljer.
Samtidigt så är det också den resan vi har gjort på ett framgångsrikt sätt där vi ändå har lyckats att anpassa produkter och ta fram mer relevanta produkter för målgrupper som inte behöver den absolut sista promillen i tolerans eller i prestande.
Så den är ständigt med.
Och det man kan äta liknande är att det är det...
Vi har som mål att alltid utveckla en kvänningsägg.
Då kommer vår marknad och vår potentiella tillväxt vara väldigt låg.
Men är det så att vi ändå kan på något sätt utveckla mer mot en...
Ta en Porsche eller något som är mer prestanda, mycket det men inte har den här ultimata delen alltid, så då är det en större marknad för oss.
Det är väldigt lätt nu.
De som inte är helt insatta i Laco får liksom...
Jag får be om ursäkt till dem.
Men era skivstänger är ju väldigt...
De är ju verkligen etablerade på något sätt.
Det måste ju vara ganska golden standard i branschen på något sätt över större delen av världen.
Blir det liksom skumt för er när ni tar fram, om vi säger till exempel en kettebäll eller en skivstångställning som inte alls har samma krav på sig, hur ser redan utväxlingsprocessen på er ut?
Jag ser framför mig att ni sitter tre personer i ett rum.
En person som är såhär, nej, det måste vara den bästa kettebällen världen har sett.
Och så sitter någon annan på andra sidan bordet och bara, det är ju en kettebäll, kan du slappna av lite där borta på andra sidan.
Och så sitter du någonstans i mitten och säger att vi ska kunna sälja den också.
Ja, jag tror att det är, samtidigt så är det ju detta, alltså vi är ju en specialist.
Och vi fokuserar på styrketräning och egentligen en särskild typ av styrketräning som är väldigt lutad åt fria vikter, åt lyftning, åt funktionell träning.
Och mot performance driven träning.
Vi kommer ju från idrotten, vi har rötterna i professionell idrott.
Och vi bryr oss ju väldigt mycket om den här delen av marknaden.
Så våra produkter som vi utvecklar lägger vi väldigt mycket hjärta och skäl i.
Och detaljerna är jätteviktiga för oss.
Det är väl egentligen en av delarna som verkligen skiljer oss åt jämfört med många andra som vi konkurrerar med och agerar med inom utrustningsbranschen.
Det är ju inga andra företag skulle jag säga som lägger den typen av engagemang och dedikering till fria vikter någon annanstans i världen.
Och det gör vi för att vi brinner för det, vi har vårt arv, vi har vår position, vi har vår koppling till alla idrottare och lyftare runt om i världen.
Det där är egentligen en styrka hos oss.
Och det är det som gör att vi hela tiden kan utveckla produkterna och göra dem ännu lite bättre varje år, varje lansering.
Så det är egentligen någonting som jag från mitt håll sätt försöker verkligen vårda och vända till någonting positivt.
Sen kommer det ju ofta just hur man anpassar en produkt för att ändå nå så stor marknad som möjligt, men det är ett ständigt arbete.
Hur jobbar ni med samarbeten och att nå ut?
Ni gör ju ganska lite, det är ju inte er vi slåss med i Google Ads-resultaten så att säga, utan hur jobbar ni med marknadsföring och att nå ut mot kunder?
Nej, jag pratar via samma marknadsspend eller marknadsstrategi, utan jag förstår väl att ni jobbar mycket mer med att köpa annonser och nå ut på det sättet.
Vi jobbar väldigt mycket med relationer och vi har ju nära samarbete med en rad federationer och förbund på internationell nivå, kontinental nivå, nationell nivå, klubbnivå där vi jobbar nära dem.
Det är inte endast inom psykiidrotten utan vi vänder oss till andra idrotter också.
Relationsdelen och sen på det sättet att nå ut och verkligen vara på de främsta anläggningarna i världen.
När vi är på anläggning med vår utrustning det är då vi kommer i kontakt med utövarna, med atleterna, med idrotterna eller medlemmarna.
Så vi har en annorlunda marknadsföringsstrategi på det sättet.
Hur ofta blir ni utmanade om de positionerna?
Finns det liksom x antal aktörer i världen som försöker pusha bort er från den här OS-tronen eller vad vi ska kalla det?
Det finns andra företag.
I varje specifikt sport så har man ofta ett antal företag som är certifierade, tillåtna och godkända av förbundet att leverera.
Det kan vara fem, sex stycken i en sport som ett exempel.
Där är det alltid konkurrens.
Alla tävlingar vi levererar till är konkurrensutsatta.
I vissa fall är det företag som gör viktiga ansatser och försöker ta vår position.
Den utsätts vi för hela tiden.
Tittar man sedan inom det kommersiella segmentet så är det mer att man ser att det finns i varje land, eller i varje land så finns det ofta någon lokal champion, eller någon duktig lokal aktör.
Inte alltid som utvecklar egna produkter, men som kanske har en del egna produkter och säljer en del andra produkter också.
Det är en typ av konkurrent i oss.
Sen är det ju på global nivå ser vi mer de större, kompletta utrustningsleverantörerna.
Där finns det väl en handfull ungefär, som är globala och stora som konkurrerar.
Det är väl där vi egentligen har gjort en resa, där vi har förr i tiden jobbat och verkat mer på den här lokala nivån, men nu är vi mycket mer uppe och tar andelar från de större.
Det är mycket i den resan som jag tycker är spännande att göra också med bolaget att verkligen lyfta det till den nivån så att vi kan bli en riktigt ledande global aktör i Europa, i USA, i Asien och i Sydamerika.
Det är väldigt spännande, jag tänker att vi ska fastna i det.
Hur stor del av er försäljning är i Sverige kontra utomlands?
Vi har 85% av vår försäljning, lite drygt, är export.
Det är häftigt ändå.
Och det är Europa, de större marknaderna i Europa som är tillsammans med USA, de största delarna, men vi säljer ju till 120 länder varje år.
Min feeling är att Mellanöstern har vuxit jättemycket i styrkesegment och sånt.
Märker ni också av det?
Ja det märker vi, det här är ett stort intresse i Mellanöstern efter den här typen av produkter.
Och det är ju flera länder som satsar väldigt mycket på både sport och på hälsa.
Så att det här händer jättemycket och det är stora satsningar och där är vi definitivt med.
Visst säljer ni Precor fortfarande?
Ni har agenturen för den?
Ja, jag har ett samarbete med Precor som gäller för Norden.
Den där är så etablerade så om vi har sån infrastruktur då har vi utvecklat ett samarbete med Precor som är en av de här större globala aktörerna.
Då kombinerar vi vår styrketräningsutrustning med deras övriga utrustning, mycket inom konditionsdelen och på det sättet kan vi bli en total leverantör.
Ut i världen så är vi en väldigt tydlig specialist som fokuserar på en viss yta på gymmet där styrketräning då är representerat.
Okej, för min fråga var lite i den här globala expansionen, är tanken att ni ska fortsätta vara en specialiserad aktör, är det positivt att vara det eller är tanken att ni ska gå in och ta en breda, alltså ni har ju till exempel de senaste åren gjort de här presterasystemen som är litegrann åt cablecross-hållen, så de rör sig ändå in mot maskinparken, men vad jag vet så har ni fortfarande inga rena latsrodd och benspark, alltså hela maskinparken på det sättet eller kondition.
Vi har en tydlig kränsdragning när det gäller styrka, kondition och övrigt.
Så att Eleiko är fokuserat på styrketräningsutrustning och styrketräningsutytan på gymmen.
Även inom den delen så är vi idag väldigt specialiserade på mer frieviktig, funktionellt lyftning.
Sen som du säger, vi har lanserat ett system för stationärstyrka.
Det är egentligen all typ av utrustning, rack, plattformar, riggar, förvaring som man använder för att aktivera frievikter.
Men vi har också rört oss in och lanserat en linje med kabelmaskiner.
Jag tror att det är ändå ganska tydligt att vi är på en resa där vi successivt kommer växa inom styrketräningskategorin.
Så vi har det som en tydlig strategi och arbete som pågår.
Jag förstår, men kommer vi, klart du kanske inte kan säga aldrig eller säga när, men kommer vi få se en leikomaskinserie på typ femton maskiner för styrketräning?
Ligger det liksom i korten, är det så tankarna går?
Det ligger i korten och sen får du ändå säga att det kommer i så fall ske med grund i den filosofin vi har kring styrketräning.
Som ändå är väldigt inriktad på att man ska träna funktionellt.
Full range of motion.
Att man ska träna för att kunna prestera bättre.
Mindre muskelspecifikt och mer rörelsespecifikt.
Så att vi kommer ändå att ha en väldigt tydlig koppling med allt vi gör i framtiden till där vi kommer ifrån.
Och det är det som är vår expertis.
Okej, jag fattar.
Det är bara en principgrej som gör att ni har dragit.
På något sätt blir det lite halvsvårt att dra den där gränsdragningen exakt vart den ska.
Ja, nu jag köper, ni går in i kryssdrag men, eller jag bara förenklar, du vill säkert kalla det någonting annat, men ni går in i kryssdrag men det är ju inte jättelångt ifrån att sätta på en sits och så har du ett latsdrag och då kan du sätta in ett rodddrag och sen går du vidare till att göra någon sorts bröstvariant på det med något tryck.
Alltså vem är det som avgör den där gränsdragningen och varför spelar det någon roll egentligen?
Nej men gränsdragningen är ju som jag sa styrka eller inte.
Och allt det du nämner är ju styrketräning för mig.
Så det är ju saker som vi skulle kunna och kan göra på ett väldigt bra sätt.
Så att den gränsdragningen tycker jag egentligen är tydlig.
Vem är det som driver utvecklingen kring produkt?
Vad gör, vi har helt glömt att prata om det i detta, det är bara för att jag fastnade i allt andra intressanta, men vad gör du på dagarna?
Produktdelen är ju en stor del av det jag lägger min tid på.
Vi har en ledningsgrupp som är organiserad på ett sätt där de flesta andra delarna, men just produktdelen ligger på mitt bord.
Sen har vi en produktutvecklingschef och vi har en produktchef för sortimentet som jobbar med det operativa.
Men när det gäller att sätta produktroadmap och med i det arbetet och verkligen säkerställa att produkterna är av det slaget och på den nivån som vi vill så är det ju en stor del av det jag jobbar med.
Är det för att du är bäst på det eller är det för att du tycker det är roligast?
Nej men jag brinner för det.
Jag gillar verkligen att vara nära produkten och det är på något sätt hjärtat i Läkå, både som bolag och som varumärke, att det är produkten som förmedlar vad vi står för.
Med kvalitet och med funktion och med den svenska, skandinaviska designen och hur det är med att verkligen verka ut det på anläggningar.
Så att det är både hjärtat och att det är bra för businessen tror jag, att jag lägger mycket tid på det.
Under covid så hade vi någon sorts crossfit boom i Sverige och ni var ju ganska etablerade i den utrullningen.
Jag tycker att ganska många aktörer valde i Läkå i den, men framförallt med era friviktssystem, eller vad vi ska kalla det.
Men en annan aktör som var väldigt involverad i crossfit var ju Rogue av naturliga anledningar, eftersom de körde hela gamesgrejen.
Men på något sätt så har ju de tappat lite sin framåtanda, kanske lite i takt med att crossfit inte alls har samma tillväxt idag.
Det blev ju inte direkt som padelbo, men den sten dog ju.
Men crossfit har ju liksom stannat av och liksom, ja men det har hänt mycket där liksom.
Hur tänkte ni kring att inte bli för förknippade kring ett annat varumärke?
Och jag har lite samma fråga på när ni jobbar med pre-core till exempel.
För att på något sätt så sätter ni ju ert varumärke i en rörelse, eller i pre-core fall så blir det att ni sätter in det i nu levererar vi de här maskinerna, och om de då helt plötsligt levererar dåligt i sin tur till er så blir ju er att varumärke lidande.
Och ni har ju liksom på något sätt spesat er som att det vi jobbar på den här procenten.
Och det är lite läskigt och det är samma sak som Crossfit då till exempel.
Det har hänt massa grejer där.
Hur gör man för att inte liksom tappa sitt momentum och bli förförknippad med den världen när det kommer nya händelser?
När det gäller just Crossfit så tycker jag det är en väldigt intressant fråga.
För det var ju väldigt tydligt då när Crossfit bröt igen och man verkligen växte väldigt kraftigt 2010 och framåt kan man säga det.
Även kanske något år innan det.
Och man sa att det var väldigt många aktörer som kom in i branschen, nya företag som började tillverka utrustning.
Och som du nämnde då amerikanska RÅ där var ju starka och starkt förknippade med själva Crossfit varumärket och Crossfit företaget.
Så vi tänkte ganska mycket på just den biten och vi sa att vi aldrig skulle egentligen gå all in på det planet.
Utan vad vi gjorde var att vi verkligen såg till att vi hade ett väldigt väl anpassat sortiment för den delen.
Men vi såg också ganska tidigt hur Crossfit var en väldigt organisk deltag där och rörde sig in på andra kommersiella gym.
Till en början var det just under det varumärket och sen är det någonting annat, en performanceyta på en gymskedja eller de skapar sitt egna koncept.
Det var kanske mer tävlingsform än Crossfit som blev det som verkligen blev varumärket mycket.
Och sen utifrån gymmet så blev det mer en annan typ av träning eller ett annat sätt att utöva styrketräning på.
Så vi jobbade ganska mycket med den frågan faktiskt.
Därför sa vi aldrig att vi var ett Crossfitföretag eller att vi hade nog inte ens det som en riktigt högst prioriterad del heller i vårt arbete.
Utan vi försökte medjobba med vår linje och sen att det vi gör kommer att träffa Crossfit bland annat, men också andra saker som händer utifrån marknaden.
För jag tror att så många aktörer som gavs in just när en sån trend var så stark, det är många företag som inte är kvar, som dök upp, men gjorde bra ifrånset på år och sen är de inte kvar.
Jag tror att det är en risk, en stor risk när det är sådana saker att man verkligen hakar på någonting och helt förknippar sig och knyter sig till det när det inte är tydligt var det kommer landa någonstans.
Tror du att folk kommer att göra samma misstag med Hi-Rox uppgången?
Hi-Rox är egentligen samma typ av våg och sen är det väldigt skickligt gjort och de tar en helt annan approach när det gäller just att integrera sitt koncept med andra aktörer.
Det är väl egentligen det som är skillnaden här att CrossFit var väldigt, de styrde det väldigt mycket och ville verkligen kontrollera hela CrossFit-miljön, i alla fall initialt.
Man ser på Hi-Rox att de har verkligen jobbat och jobbar nära en rad olika aktörer just nu för att integrera det.
Det kanske också är något lättare del att skapa ut det på anläggningar än vad CrossFit var.
Det var mer styrt, tycker jag, från början.
Mycket är att man egentligen använder utrustning som finns på anläggningar och möjliga för highrox-formatet.
Men det kan mycket väl vara att det är ett liknande förlopp här.
Jag tror mer, det kom även in på en kulturell del att CrossFit blev en sån jättestark kultur efter ett tag, när det formades och det verkligen blev och så var det tävlingsdelen.
I början är det väldigt inkluderande och sen när det blir väldigt homogent och fast som kultur så blir det ju till viss del lite exkluderande också.
Och jag tror att det är det som alla de här nya formaten och varumärkena och trenderna har att tänka mycket på, hur behåller man den här inkluderande delen samtidigt som man också måste bygga en väldigt stark kultur.
Så det är väldigt intressant att följa och vi är ju med lite på alla håll här när sånt här händer.
Om vi tar gymmekompaniet här som exempel så har ju vi börjat röra oss in i motion till exempel och tagit, börjat ta in egna löpande och liknande sånt där.
Och det är ju en pissjobbig situation eftersom löpande är det som går sönder på gym liksom.
Så då måste man hantera mycket service och liknande och det får man ju hantera.
Men Eleiko har ju en extrem fördel i att i princip alla era produkter är ju saker som man inte behöver lösa så mycket service på.
Man kanske behöver skicka ut en ny hantel om någon har gått sönder.
När ni började jobba med pre-core och ni fick hantera hela den maskinparken med allt det gäller med serviceavtal och tekniker och reservdelar.
Hur mycket ångrade du beslutet att börja jobba?
Jag bara förutsätter att det var en shitstorm av skit som ni skulle hantera.
Hur mycket ångrade du det beslutet där någon gång?
Två år in.
Det är ju en del av vår business som vi gör och som jag nämnde i Norden.
Där vi är så pass stora och starka resursmässigt att vi kan hantera total leveranser och verkligen jobba med servicedelen och den biten.
Så det är definitivt en annan del än om du bara skickar fler vikter till en kund.
Samtidigt är det också det som vi har blivit väldigt bra på genom åren.
Det var ett drillat svar, hur tråkigt var det ett år innan.
Ja, om du tänker på Preco, vi jobbade med andra partners innan det så vi började egentligen 2004.
Då började vi med partners inom konditioner och inom styrkemaskiner också.
Då var jag inte med första åren, men det är klart att det är en mer komplex produkt och det kräver en helt annan organisation.
Men jag vill ändå säga att det är någonting vi ändå jobbat med i 20 år.
Okej, jag trodde att det var då ni drog igång.
Men jobbar ni med gym 8 innan?
Ja, vi har haft det om också som ett samarbete.
Vi har jobbat med Free Motion och vi har jobbat med lite olika aktörer.
Intensa har varit med också under en tid.
Och det är för att verkligen kunna vara den här totalleverantören.
Sen är det ju där vi investerar våra produktutveckling och marknadsföring och då är det ju i Eleiko varumärket och Eleiko sortimentet.
Så det är ju där produktion och hela den biten.
Så där är ju var vi lägger våra investeringar.
Jag har faktiskt varit och hälsat på er ett par gånger.
Jag tror inte att vi har sett, jag tror inte det men...
Nej, jag har inte sett det.
Vi har följt er så mycket i alla dina inlägg och annat.
Jag tycker det är en väldigt rolig resa att följa er också.
Jag har varit nere i Halmstad ett par gånger och sett er lager där och jag hade med din kollega här i podden för kan det vara två år sedan eller någonting när den var mer renodlat, träningsfokuserad.
Men jag går ju igång på det här med svensk produktion och jag har liksom försökt få igång det.
Jag drev det med förlust i två och ett halvt år.
Vi satte upp en verkstad i Tranås till exempel och försökt verkligen få till det.
För jag tycker att det finns någonting vackert i det.
Hur stor del är i leikoproduktion idag?
Du behöver inte nämna exakta grejer, men är målet att allting ska vara svenskproducerat?
Och hur löser ni?
Det är två väldigt skilda verksamhetsområden att jobba med produktion, och att jobba med distribution, och att jobba med försäljning.
Det finns ju en anledning till att de flesta köper från fabrik och inte själva driver produktion.
Kan vi inte prata lite om bara produktionen?
Vi har egen produktion här i Hamstads.
Och sen har vi mycket produktioner i Sverige.
Och tar man skivstången så har vi den verkligen.
Det är en del av vårt arv kan man säga.
Så vi har ju verkligen byggt upp både kompetens och effektivitet när det gäller att tillverka den produkten.
Men det är också någonting vi aldrig skulle vilja.
Det kommer vi inte att lämna ut.
I alla fall inte under mitt lederskap i det här företaget.
Så den är ju kärna för oss.
Men vi tillverkar hantla här också.
Vi gör en del stål, ställningar och annat.
Vi har ju en gummifabrik här i Hamstads som tillverkar ett par av våra gummiskivor.
Och sen har vi mycket i Småland.
Duktiga mekaniska verkstäder som tillverkar och samarbetar med oss.
Det är en viktig del, men det är inte så heller att vi säger att allt måste vara tillverkat i Sverige.
Man måste också se på att vissa delar är vi inte så bra på i Sverige och vissa delar går inte att konkurrera med prismässigt.
Om man tar med vissa gjutna produkter så är det väldigt svårt att hitta leverantörer, till och med i Europa, som kan tillverka det på en rimlig nivå.
Vi är definitivt öppna med det.
Och där finns det också många kluster ut i världen där de har byggt väldigt bra kompetens kring det.
Men det är klart, jag gillar svensk tillverkning, jag gillar verkligen att kan vi göra en produkt själva till rätt pris och så vill vi göra det.
Vi tog in en ny klove här som vi tappt fram för hela tävlingsdelen som vill tillverka i princip komplett i vår fabrik.
Och det är jättekul och vi kan göra det till rätt pris och vi får väldigt bra kvalitetskontroll och möjlighet att verkligen förfina det.
Så jag gillar det väldigt mycket och om rätt, där man säger maskininvestering, rätt automation och rätt, så tycker jag att det faktiskt går bra.
Är det lönsamma att driva er, för du sa att ni samarbetar med flera ställen, men ni har ju också egen produktion.
Vad är det som avgör om ni ska driva er själva och lägga det...
Ni har ju ett ganska, vad ska vi kalla det då, evergreen-sortiment.
Fan vad jag höjer upp er i den här, jag får nästan vara lite kritisk.
Vi är ju, nu ses vi inte jättemycket i offertkamper mot varandra och så där liksom, men vi är ju ändå på någon sorts planhalva konkurrenter, men folk får ta det med en klackspark här.
Men ni har ju ett ganska bra evergreen-sortiment, det är inte så att ni byter ut...
Alltså om ni tar fram en produkt kommer ni antagligen sälja den under en relativt lång framtid.
Är det inte alltid positivt att ta in det i egen produktion då?
Eller varför bestämmer man att någon annan ska tillverka den om det ändå är i Sverige?
Det har att göra med volymer, och det har att göra med vilka investeringar som krävs i maskiner.
Och vissa produkter har vi ju först kanske jobbat med någon extern leverantör och sen då tagit in.
Men man ska ju känna att volymen finns där, att den ska vara väldigt stabil och tillverklig för att fylla en produktionslinje eller en maskin.
Det är ju de bitarna som...
Och där blir det ju alltid en konkurrens med...
Man har ju bara så mycket pengar att lägga på saker och det är klart att vi värderar väldigt högt produktutveckling.
Vi lägger väldigt mycket på att utveckla sortimentet och hela tiden förbättra det.
Det har blivit avvägande också vad är viktigast just nu.
Är det att investera i en ny maskin eller är det att sätta igång ett nytt intressant utvecklingsprojekt.
Och det är klart, vi viktar väldigt mycket mot att verkligen bli ett väldigt starkt utvecklingsbolag.
Ni gjorde ju under covid, det kändes som ni hade en ganska snabb lansering där innan så jobbade ni med återförsäljare.
Vi var en av era återförsäljare och sålde lite elekostänger och viktskivor och sådär.
Och sen, jag vet inte om ni stängde ner under covid mot återförsäljare eller om det var strax, jag minns inte exakt timelineen där, men ni lanserade ju liksom en egen webbshop för försäljning och det tror jag inte att ni hade innan, utan då var det nog mer.
Nej covid var det, vi hade det på bordet redan lite lätt innan covid hände.
Men sen när det hände förstås, det var ju som att, stänga av kranen när det gällde business to business-försäljning.
Och det har ju alltid varit vår större del.
Så det tog ju stopp helt enkelt.
Och på stora marknader, USA, tog det ju stopp helt och hållet.
Vi hade inte en order till en business to business-kund på tre månader.
Men då såg vi samtidigt vad som hände med att kranen öppnades när det gällde hemma-träning.
Så vi satte ihop och lanserade en e-handelsplattform snabbt.
Och det var egentligen det som bar oss 2020-2021.
Det var väl stark efterfrågan från hemma-kunder.
Och i vårt fall så kunde vi skifta om väldigt kvickt där.
Och då såg vi att många av de större aktörerna tappade försäljning under den tiden.
Och vi fortsatte att öka.
Så det var en intressant tid.
Samtidigt ser det också så när efterfrågmönstren skiftade tillbaka 2022 och framåt.
Då tog vi också tydligt beslut där.
Det är inte e-handel som är vår styrka eller vårt fokus just nu.
Så vi kommer att ha en del där.
Vi kommer att ha ett begränsat sortiment för de som är dedikerade till den typen av produkt och utövaren som vi vänder oss till.
Men vi lägger verkligen våra resurser och fokus på att utveckla de här business to business-digglarna.
Men också möjligtvis att man kallar det mer den här premiumhemmakunden som kanske investerar mer i ett gym på liknande sätt som en business to business-kunn som behöver en del konsultation och en del expertis och rådgivning.
Och även söker en produkt därefter.
Ja men den är fortfarande intressant och växande för oss.
Jag tänkte säga hur stor är e-handeln idag?
Det känns inte som att det är en så stor del av er.
För vår del är e-handeln en mindre del, så det är ett par procent vi pratar.
Så att vi är främätet, alltså våra kanaler är vår egen säljstyrka.
I de länder där vi inte har egen personal så har vi distributörer.
Och sen en väldigt liten del på e-handel.
Ni hade ju några återförsäljare innan, jag vet inte hur många vi var som sålde i Leiko i Sverige, men säga att vi var tre eller fyra eller något sånt där.
Jag kan ju spontant se att det är positivt att stänga ner det återförsäljareledet.
Och framförallt nu under lågkonjunkturen har det skett en absurd prispress i vår bransch och väldigt mycket, det finns ju flera aktörer som har kört rea i fyra år på hela sina sortiment.
Var det det som var det stora målet med att stänga ner det, eller var det mer att det här är vårt, varumärken hur vi ska leda in dem på vår e-handel i samband med covid, eller hur gick?
Jag tror att båda de två bitarna spelar en roll.
Ett sätt är att när vi bygger vårt varumärke globalt, så är det ju mer vi kan styra och kontrollera i det arbetet desto bättre, anser vi.
Så det är ett sätt att verkligen säkerställa att varumärket förmedlas på rätt sätt.
Men sen är det också att vi inte har det så volymmässigt.
För den volymen och det arbete som man då ändå måste lägga på, att ha en kanal öppen på det sättet, så har vi inte vi ansett att det är värt det.
Det är ju mycket diskussioner med det också hos oss.
Det är väldigt lätt att tänka att man har ett starkt varumärke, ett starkt produkt och i handel att vara så mycket på väg framåt.
Så klart vi ska göra det, vi ska göra det med kraft.
Vi ska göra det med det i alla länder, i EU, USA, alla platser.
Men kanalen, det är en jätteviktig faktor att verkligen, har man kanalstykan eller inte, både organisatoriskt och även produktmässigt, eller har man inte?
Och vår kanalstyka, vi är verkligen duktiga på det här med att jobba business to business, mycket konsultativ del i försäljningen, jobba i relationer, jobba nära kunden, jobba med projekt.
Och det är klart, vi skulle kunna ta ett beslut att vi vill lägga våra resurser på att bygga upp liknande styrka inom e-handel, men vi har inte gjort det och har inte sett det ännu.
Jag köper, jag kan nog spontant från sidlinjen tycka att det är en ganska sund idé sådär, och dessutom så är det ju, vi säljer liksom inte de smidigaste logistiska produkterna, utan ska man skicka en skivstång till Rumänien så kommer ju den skivstången att kasta ganska mycket.
Alltså det finns ju en funktion i att sälja projekt snarare än att sälja produkter.
E-handel är ju inte riktigt lämpat för gymutrustning på det sättet.
Nej, det har ju den, det är inte den lättaste produkten att skicka.
Jag skulle bara vilja avsluta lite grann ni att fastna om varumärkesarbeten.
Hur gör ni för att bibehålla?
För ni gör ändå relativt lite marknadsföring med tanke på storleken på bolaget får man ändå säga.
Sen syns ni ju som sagt givetvis i massa olika områden.
Men är det det som är er marknadsföring?
Är det så ni ser på marknadsföring att ni ska synas på rätt tävlingar och på rätt gymmor?
Vi tänker mycket, vi jobbar ju mycket med att komma ut och verkligen nå ut till rätt platser, rätt anläggningar.
Där egentligen rätt utövare kommer i kontakt med våra produkter.
Vi lägger förstås pengar på marknadsföring också.
Vi jobbar delvis mycket med content och att nå ut i våra egna kanaler och i våra partners kanaler.
Den är ju definitivt med där.
Men vi jobbar inte mycket med den här konkreta att köpa annonser för en produkt eller att alltså den typen av aktivering jobbar inte.
Utan vi jobbar mycket med att bygga varumärket.
Varumärket är nyckeln för oss.
Och sen om vi lyckas bygga varumärket starkt och vi lyckas få flera att komma i kontakt med det, då tror vi att det kommer att driva försäljning också.
Så att varumärket är väldigt centralt för det vi gör.
Har ni någon sorts sån här drömbild i huvudet som ni alltid utgår ifrån?
Ja men det ska vara spetskompetens eller det ska vara, eller är det bara, alltså typ Volvo jobbar ju med säkerhet, det är typ det de pushar.
Har ni någon sån där grej som ni verkligen...
Ja det är klart kvalitet och prestanda eller performance är ju nyckelattribut för oss.
Så det som du frågar väldigt många som köper våra och använder produkten så är det ju kvalitet och performance delen och precisionen som många kommer tillbaka till och det är viktigt för oss.
Det är på något sätt där vi etablerar produkten som den ledande produkten inom sitt slag.
Men sen gör det mycket.
Vi har ju en strategi också där vi ändå vänder oss mycket i vår kommunikation till utövaren.
Man ser ju alltså, tittar man på de här stora aktörerna som jag nämnde innan, det är inte de som säljer allt inom träningsutrustning.
Men då är ju deras fokus ofta mer på köparen och inköpschefen eller ägaren till anläggningen.
Så att det stannar ofta där.
Men vi vänder oss i hur vi kommunicerar så vänder vi oss väldigt mycket till vilken känsla får utövaren.
Med våra produkter.
Hur connectar de med vår skivstånd, våra hantlar, våra kablar, våra dygnor.
Så detaljerna är viktiga och just att tala till de som använder produkten.
Och på det sättet så skapar vi också ett form av vi får en kraft också utifrån anläggningen att medlemmar borde uppskatta väldigt mycket om vår utrustning kommer in på en anläggning.
Men också att det i många fall efterfrågas vår utrustning gentemot då är den som köper in.
Och det tror jag skiljer oss en del mot vad de stora aktörerna gör för de har inte det fokuset och därför tycker inte jag heller de bygger varumärken på det sättet.
De har starkare varumärken gentemot en inköpare men de har inte, tycker jag, nått ut med det till utövaren.
Och jag tror på sikt att utövaren är jätteviktig.
Du menar på något sätt att gymägaren använder nästan er man säger nu har vi köpt in en hantelsektion här från Eleiko och då blir det nästan deras marknadsföring för gymmet, är det så?
Ja, precis.
Det blir en kvalitetsstämpel på gymmet och det visar att operatören förstår träning och den typer av träning.
Så det är ofta det vi ser, men det är många kunder till oss som verkligen vill jobba med vårt varumärke utepå deras anlägg.
När vi har en historieväg här där vi berättar mycket om vår historia och vår resa.
Och det är ett antal kunder som vill ha precis samma utepå deras gym och berätta just om Eleiko och varför de har valt att ha Eleiko på utrustningen eller på anläggningen.
För att de märker att det blir en positiv effekt hos dem.
Hur mycket bryr sig folk i Tyskland typ om Eleiko?
Alltså i Sverige är ju Eleiko ett välkänt märke om man vet liksom vad det står för, men vet liksom en standardbesökare i Tyskland vad Eleiko är, eller bryr sig om.
Jag fattar i Sverige att man kan använda det.
Jag tror att det är så att vi pratar egentligen om ju mer kompetent än, eller det är så jag ser på det, ju mer kompetent än en person som tränar är inom styrketräning.
Och särskilt under en upplyftning.
Det står troligare redan att de känner till Eleiko och även förstår vad Eleiko handlar om.
Så det är på något sätt en kompetensresa där som många gör.
Och tittar man då inom de som lyfter, styrkelyft, tynglyftning, de som tränar ofta inom idrottsvärlden, ja men där har Eleiko ett jättestarkt varumärke runtom i världen.
Och jag skulle säga att i Sverige så är det ju mer att, som du säger, det är etablerat, flera känner till Eleiko och det finns det på väldigt många anläggningar här.
Men ut i världen så är det verkligen de som kan träning, de känner till Eleiko.
Och där har de en jättehög aktning för varumärket och för produkten.
Tyngdlyftning och styrkorift, det är ju intressant att det är en av de kanske idrotterna som utövar sig på absolut flest platser runtom i världen.
Och i många länder så är tyngdlyftningen väldigt, väldigt stor som sport.
Inte sällan i länder som är ganska autoritära och har som mål att verkligen vinna OS-medaljer och visa att de har en stark population och starka människor.
Så att vi när vi är uten resa kommer vi till länder där de har en syn på Eleiko som att det är verkligen ett globalt världsledande, nästan varumärke och bolag.
Så det är nästan mer det jag får kämpa mot i vissa fall, att ändå på alla och förstå att man måste ha rätt förväntan här också på det.
Men detta är den svenska resan vi gör tycker jag.
Men vi är ett svenskt företag, vi är verkligen verksamma ut i världen.
Vi har ett starkt varumärke, vi växer, vi har vuxit under hela min tid här.
Sedan jag började 2012, vi rör oss, vi närmar oss miljarder nu i omsättningen och håller på att bli miljardföretag.
Vi hade 900 miljoner förra året.
Och jag tycker att vi håller på att bryta oss ut från en grupp här där vi verkligen kan utmana de här stora aktörerna på ett jättespännande sätt.
Inom den delen som vi då väljer att verka inom.
Första åren här som jag jobbade så var vi verkligen under radan på många håll.
Nu tycker jag inte att vi är under radan på samma sätt, utan nu är det mer det vi gör, det syns ute och det är många som tittar på oss.
Och då tänker jag inte bara på Sverige, jag tänker ute i de större länderna också.
Och det är väldigt kul, resa, det är väldigt spännande och det triggar alla här på företaget.
Vi är verkligen med och gör saker som syns och som uppskattas.
Jag bara önskar er ett stort lycka till.
Tack så mycket för att du var med i podden Erik och snackade om Eleiko.
Tack så mycket själv och tack för jättefina podd och fina inlägg som jag kommer fullständigt följa.
Det här måste vara den bästa kättebällen världen har sett.
Och så sitter någon annan på andra sidan bordet och bara det är ju en kättebäll, kan du slappna av lite där borta?